how they might work grab a beer bottle
and a $1 bill
now place the dollar on top of the beer
bottle then place four quarters on top
of the dollar now remove the dollar
without touching or knocking over the
quarters prepare for someone to look
really stupid right now I don't even
know how to go about this all right
enlike are there any rules for like my
hands like there's like one hand on the
bottle my my first instinct is to just
like yank it really says I'm sure no one
else has tried this too if I like blow
maybe one way and like keep that intact
like maybe okay blowing can't be that
can't be the solution that
[Music]
okay I was gonna flip the bottle upside
down is that legal
is this legal oh my gosh I know there's
an easy way and if you tell me I'm
really gonna be pissed
[Music]
hold it no I just like
[Music]
that's how you just scoop him I know
this is smarter than this I was in
advanced classes in school but maybe
some sort of tapping will get the dollar
out was I warm when I like folded it
[Music]
I don't know what to do I'm sorry mom
and I'm sorry dad
lick your finger slap the dollar
[Music]
what
[Applause]
oh my god that's pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
what whoa that was like the coolest
thing you like licked it and smacked it
in such a cool way that sounds really
nice
[Music]